[Musique]
une petite chorale qui demande à être
accompagné par le compositeur Gilbert
bcco voilà c'est la chorale Les les
Petits Chanteurs à la tête de bois step
Françoise HUG et gilola et ils chantent
une chanson enfin donnez-leur le ton
maestro voilà prenez le
ton
allons-y est comme lui pantal d'un blous
quand on les rencontre la nuit
de
garçons jeis
masqué ils ont des jeux
dangereux qui trouve le
[Musique]
JO suite la
suite il ne se sent jamais dit le plus
petit mot d'amour
il se balade dans la vie ouais en copain
de
toujours il pense que c'est démodé de se
l'avouer qu'ils aiment ils ont des jous
de Gamain mais le cœur est déjà loin
c'est le temps est n'importe
quoi ils vont tous les jours tous les
jours au cinéma quand ils sortent du
ciné ils prennent un Coca-Cola et comme
des habitués ils écoutent la machine qui
fait
elle s'habille comme lui dans pantalon
blousant quand on les regarde de la nuit
on dirait deux
garçons leur visage paraît masqué mais
moi moi je le sais qu'il sa ils sont des
jeux dans Dereux c'est là qu'ils
trouvent leur joie c'est le temps et
n'importe quoi à je tendrai tête de bois
il se jettent dans la lui en l'écrasant
des chemins à grand coup de Sagre et de
bruit il prennent le
chemin et quand il se retrouve au jour
la route est toujours la même
c'est parce qu'il presque rien qu'il
voudrait n'importe quoi c'est le temps
n'importe quoi
T et tête de
bois